plusieurs mois déjà d'ailleurs la russie
vous le savez hamas des troupes à la
frontière ukrainienne thomas et doom a
rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir thomas de
l'équipe des observateurs de france 24
vous avez regardé les dernières photos
satellites qui existe qu'est ce que ces
photos nous montrent et bien la regarder
les camps et les bases de l'armée russe
tout autour de l'ukraine à l'on constate
un accroissement de cette présence
militaire si l'on regarde cette carte on
s'aperçoit effectivement qu'il ya une
concentration au nord de l'ukraine en
biélorussie à l'est au nord-est et au
sud de l'ukraine dans la crim est
annexée mais ces derniers jours sur
certaines des images satellites que nous
avons pu voir on s'est aperçu que deux
grands camps militaires russes avaient
été vidées parfois parfois quasi
totalement comme par exemple ce qu'en un
seul outil à 24 kilomètres de la
frontière avec l'ukraine dans le
nord-est le camp a été vidé le 20
février cette image montre le camp avec
des colonnes de véhicules dans la neige
on en compte plusieurs dizaines sur la
seconde photo qui a été prise le même
jour on voit que la zone est totalement
vidée de ses véhicules militaires et que
la neige a été a été retiré la russie a
annoncé un retrait partiel de ses
troupes le 15 février mais nous n'avons
vu aucune indication que les forces ont
quitté la zone frontalière pas du coup
thomas où vont ces trous et bien il
semblerait qu'une partie de ses troupes
se soient déployés dans des camps au
plus petit et plus proche de la
frontière ukrainienne comme par exemple
celui ci repéré par l'internaute coupe
sur qui se trouve près d'une ferme à
canning cas dans l'oblast de belgorod à
15 km de la frontière avec l'ukraine
elle aura il ya ces camps et puis est-ce
qu'à d'autres signes inquiétants et bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux nous avons vu
circuler des images de camions
militaires qui sont utilisés pour
transporter des prisonniers de guerre
d'après certains experts sur ces
véhicules qui ont été repris repérés
près de la frontière à belgorod on peut
apercevoir la marque z qui a été peinte
en blanc
cette marque que là nous l'avons vu à
plusieurs reprises sur d'autres
véhicules militaires qui ont été
déployés près de la frontière
ukrainienne
il pourrait s'agir d'une marque
d'identification pour permettre aux
soldats russes de se reconnaître entre
eux parce qu'une partie du matériel
qu'ils utilisent est identique ou
ressemble à celui de l'armée ukrainienne
il ya aussi d'autres images qui t'ont
qui ont été partagés sur le réseau le
tictoc où l'on peut apercevoir des
ambulances militaires où l'on distingue
une croix rouge à l'avant du camion et
enfin toujours à belgorod à 37
kilomètres de la frontière cette fois ci
un hôpital de campagne a été installé
dans un camp militaire cette photo date
d'hier on peut bien voir la croix formée
par par les tentes une disposition des
tentes similaire à celle ci nous nous en
avons trouvé une pour par comparaison
déployer cette fois-ci par l'armée russe
pendant le conflit du haut karabagh et
donc le si moscou déploie des hôpitaux
militaires et des ambulances c'est qu'il
s'attendait à subir des pertes merci
beaucoup thomas très instructif